je suis très heureuse d'avoir fait le
grand chelem dans tous les bureaux de la
ville et d'avoir un score de 50 % un peu
plus ce qui me conforte dans le fait
qu'on a essayé de tout couvrir pendant
le mandat précédent et on en récolte les
fruits mais l'entre-deux tours a été
très long et je pense que comme beaucoup
de mes collègues on a un tout petit peu
évolué et plus que jamais nous mettrons
l'humain et le quotidien au sein de
notre action by le grand chelem dans
tous les bureaux va ma porte va me
contraindre si je n'en avais déjà envie
à faire en sorte de m'occuper de
l'ensemble de la ville on a du coeur de
ville on a du renouvellement urbain
on a dû territoire d'industrie et puis
on a une plate forme de bienveillance
surveillance